mark we were talking a little earlier
about the way that sport is severing
ties with russia and confirmation in the
last few minutes from fifa the world
governing body of football and also uefa
who run the game in europe that they are
suspending all russian teams from
international competitions which is a
step that has been called for for a
couple of days now and nations have been
lining up to say that they would refuse
to play in any level against a russian
team and fifa have now finally taken the
decision they've said in a statement
fifa and uefa have today decided
together that all russian teams whether
national representative teams or club
teams shall be suspended from
participation in both fifa and uefa
competitions until further notice so
that will mean
that russia
are
very unlikely to take part in the
playoffs for the world cup for the men's
world cup that are due to be scheduled
for next month they're due to play
poland in that series of playoff games
that will not happen perhaps there will
be a replacement team the women's euro
competition is taking place in england
this summer the final here at wembley
russia very unlikely to be part of that
and spartak moscow are a club side who
are in the europa league competition in
europe they will be unable to take part
given the news of that ban that
uefa and fifa have put in place today on
a day in which the olympics have also
encouraged
sporting organizers and competitions to
ban russian and belarusian athletes a
very significant day yet again in the
world of sport as organizations and
governing bodies sever their ties with
vladimir putin's russia and there are no
exceptions this time it is a clear
suspension from fifa and uefa which
means russian involvement in coming
sporting tournaments both from club
level and also on international level
well those russian sides will not be
allowed to take part